[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina
torres sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos en esta ocasión hacemos
este programa especial gracias al
trabajo del telescopio james webb que
tomó las que hasta ahora son las
imágenes más detalladas y nítidas del
universo profundo en una misión
coordinada entre la nasa la agencia
espacial europea y la canadiense la
primera fue del cúmulo de galaxias es m
acs 07 32 como era hace 4.600 millones
de años una imagen que ya había tomado
el telescopio espacial hubble en
1995 y que aunque para el momento fue
absolutamente revelador si se compara
con la imagen del web los detalles son
impresionantes miles de galaxias
incluidos objetos con una luz sumamente
tenue que pudieron ser captados gracias
a la cámara de infrarrojo cercano cabe
aclarar que se trata de un compendio de
imágenes tomadas durante doce cinco
horas al centro de la foto es posible
ver una especie de arcos de luz que
parecen enmarcar el contorno de una
burbuja cada uno de esos arcos es una
galaxia deformada que se ve así porque
para llegar a la tierra la luz tuvo que
atravesar un lente gravitatorio pero a
qué nos referimos con esto en france24
conversamos con germán puerta integrante
de la asociación de astronomía de
colombia y esto fue lo que nos dijo lo
impresionante de esta primera imagen es
que es el campo visual en el firmamento
equivalente a un grano de arena
sostenido a la distancia de alturas y en
ese pequeñito campo visual aparecen
miles de galaxias vemos en el centro una
mancha blanca que realmente es un
conjunto una galaxia muy masiva y detrás
muy lejana
aquí una galaxia que no podemos ver con
el óptico pero aquí vemos que hay una
serie de arcos que rodean esa imagen
central eso llamado lente gravitacional
quiere decir que la luz pasa por la gran
masa y se desvía es doblar el concepto
muy relativista es doblada hacia
nosotros al ser telescopio y nos está
revelando estos datos de esa galaxia que
está muchísimo más lejana y sonido que
llama a un lente gravitacional también
fueron dadas a conocer imágenes de la
nebulosa conocida como anillo del sur
ubicada a unos 2500 años luz de
distancia de la tierra la imagen de la
izquierda es la de la cámara de
infrarrojo cercano y la de la derecha es
la de infrarrojo medio es justamente en
esta segunda donde se ven dos estrellas
por primera vez se confirma que hay dos
estrellas la segunda master está rodeada
de polvo los expertos indican que a
medida que el par de estrellas continúan
orbitando se entre si baten el gas y el
polvo produciendo patrones asimétricos
al ver el anillo del sur se habla de una
estrella que está muriendo es una
estrella moribunda tiene su proceso
final ha expulsado materia y gases
formando escudos que forman esta especie
de ojo y vemos la estrella brillante en
el centro esa no es
es un poquito a la izquierda la más
pequeñita esa es la que está pulsando la
materia pero ambas estrellas están
interactuando en en esta danza cósmica
que además un molde a
toda esta nebulosa angular el james webb
también captó un enorme mosaico del
llamado quinteto de stephan se trata de
la imagen más grande y está hecha con
cerca de mil archivos de fotografías
individuales cuatro de las galaxias
interactúan entre ellas y se ubican a
290 millones de años luz mientras que la
quinta que se ubica a la izquierda abajo
está a 40 millones de años luz de las
otras cuatro se pueden ver los arcos de
materia y gases que conectan las
galaxias y en la quinta se pueden
observar estrellas individuales incluso
el núcleo galáctico también conversamos
con diego mardones doctor en astronomía
de la universidad de harvard y esto fue
lo que nos dijo son cinco galaxias
de las cuales al menos la
las tres centrales están claramente
interactuando eso quiere decir están
chocando literalmente y al chocar salen
volando gas y estrellas en todas
direcciones algunas colas hay choques se
generan formaciones de la nueva y
algunas veces terminan en un llamado
mayor cuando se se suman las dos
galaxias y arman como una nueva no otras
veces nos pasan dos galaxias y pum
siguen así a cada uno en su camino y
entremedio quizás quirúrgicas
entonces aquí tenemos una vista
tremendamente detallada de uno de los
galaxias interactuantes
más bellas y que tiene una variedad de
cosas distintas uno puede ver núcleo
activos puede ver reacciones
individuales de formación estelar puede
ver la forma la región de interacción
también fue revelada una porción
detallada de la llamada nebulosa de
karina ubicada en el hemisferio sur una
de las nebulosas más grandes y
brillantes que está a 7 mil 600 años luz
de distancia es decir dentro de nuestra
galaxia la imagen muestra nubes de gases
y polvo en donde se incuban estrellas
estrellas jóvenes rodeadas de gases y
polvo que sirven como materia prima de
planetas karina es una estrella gigante
muy luminosa hay mucha radiación es una
región de formación de estrellas masivas
estas estrellas masivas afectan
muchísimo su medio ambiente van
erosionando van destruyendo el gas del
vecindario y ahí hay dos opciones o se
destruye todo o se crea
nuevas estrellas en base a la compresión
llega un frente hecho que la estrella
más y apunto empuje a todo y ahí nacen
nuevas estrellas o bien no pasa nada
aquí estamos viendo
entonces esta región de interacción la
parte de arriba azul es donde es pura
radiación pura luz y se ve un borde bien
definido y zonas oscuras donde en varias
partes están naciendo estrellitas nuevas
que vemos vemos un montón de sillas
pequeñitas que no conocíamos porque no
se ven en el óptico por último pero no
menos importante del análisis de la
atmósfera del exoplaneta wv esp 96 20
ubicado a mil 150 años luz de distancia
que muestra una señal inconfundible de
agua el huevo además revela la
existencia de bruma y nubes en este
planeta gigante que orbita una estrella
distante parecida a nuestro sol
lo que vemos allí es que están
analizando la esfera de ese exoplaneta
que está mil 150 años de distancia
y nos revela que hay vapor de agua en la
atmósfera inclusive la información dice
que se pueden detectar nubes y niebla
esto es emocionante porque puede
determinar
la composición de la atmósfera sexo
planetaria es tal vez encontrar huellas
de metano de carbono oxígeno revelar los
planetas que podrían tener condiciones
similares a la de la tierra y de pronto
como sucede muchas de estas misiones
nos pueden dar información de resultados
inesperados
tal vez podamos observar detalles o
imágenes directas de exoplanetas algo
que maravilla los expertos y aficionados
de este campo es que el james webb está
funcionando en perfectas condiciones el
telescopio está ubicado a un millón y
medio de kilómetros de distancia de la
tierra un punto en el que no hay
posibilidad de realizar ninguna
reparación el hubble se encuentra a 300
kilómetros de altura y cuando presentó
problemas pudo ser reparado algunas de
las imágenes captadas por el web son de
zonas que ya se conocían lo
mencionábamos antes él es el telescopio
hubble lanzado en 1990
tomó imágenes del campo profundo y
también pudo captar la los anillos del
sur no obstante la comparación en
detalle es evidente los expertos
explican el porqué de este drástico
cambio
fundamentalmente el tiempo de luz y eso
es lo más importante el telescopio webb
está optimizado para el infrarrojo
y tiene un tele un espejo y tres veces
más grande que el telescopio espacial
hubble esto quiere decir que una imagen
infrarroja con el james webb tiene la
misma calidad precisión detalle que en
el óptico para el hubble y eso hace que
la comparación sea maravillosa uno ve
una imagen del hubble en el azul o verde
amarillo rojo la compara con una imagen
infrarroja del james webb y digamos los
puntitos se ven más o menos del mismo
tamaño el nivel de detalle es similar
pero en el infrarrojo uno de más más
lejos en cosmología ve cosas que están
oscurecidas y que son invisibles en el
óptico un tema que se retoma con el
james webb y sus revelaciones es que los
telescopios nos muestran el pasado
porque muchos de los cuerpos que vemos
puede que ya no existan de la misma
forma que están en las imágenes germán
puerta nos explica a qué se debe esta
afirmación recuerden que en el espacio
cuando vemos en distancia también vemos
en el tiempo por ejemplo el sol no lo
vemos como era ahora sino como era hace
8 minutos pues ya su luz tardó ocho
minutos en llegar a nosotros a la
velocidad de la luz
bueno el solista pero cuando vemos
galaxia cristiana diez mil a dos mil
millones de años luz estamos viendo
hacia el universo primitivo como era el
universo hace dos mil millones de años
es casi seguro que esas galaxias ya no
están allí no son como las vemos hasta
ahora nos llega a su imagen de la luz
tarda
en viajar
millones en este caso miles de millones
de años y llega hasta nuestros
telescopios pero esa imagen de una de un
objeto que tal vez ya no exista por
ejemplo en el caso de alguna galaxia no
conocía que la galaxia andrómeda
está a 2.500 millones de años luz de
distancia pero nada dos millones y medio
de años de distancia de la cámara hacia
donde millones baños y es posible que
todavía sea sea así como la vemos porque
este tipo de galaxias tienen una
periodicidad muy grande cinco mil a seis
mil millones de años los expertos
explican que este tipo de revelaciones
son clave para captar la atención del
público e incluso para motivar a nuevas
generaciones a interesarse en el espacio
el road nos cambió nuestra perspectiva
del universo que teníamos universos y
lleno de objetos ahí pero más o menos
poquito para que dejó el joven nos dio
un universo de colores colores detalles
impresionantes este es mucho más potente
que el hardware el james webb es tal vez
docenas de veces más potente y seguro
que ha producido una revolución tanto en
ciencia como en la imagen final los
objetivos para los que fue lanzado el
web están claros no obstante los
expertos son conscientes de que ante
este tipo de regulaciones puede que sean
muchas más las preguntas que surjan que
las respuestas que se obtengan lo que es
la clave de los grandes avances
científicos
agradecemos a nuestros expertos y a
ustedes por habernos acompañado
continúen con nosotros en france24
france24 puntocom
a
[Música]